vu que ces dernières années le football
se joue autant devant les tribunaux que
sur le le tapis vert avec des décisions
parfois très très surprenante sans
aucune valeur d'éthique donc à un moment
donné on sait jamais mais on saura être
présent même en National on va on va pas
lâcher le le navire et on va tout faire
pour essayer de remonter l'année
prochaine c'est arrivé il y a des clubs
comme Rin tour qui ont fait l'ascenseur
et qui maintenant figurent très bien
dans les différents championnats donc
on va s'inspirer de leur expérience et
puis je pense que cette année n'a pas
été entièrement négative on a pu
améliorer nos infrastructures on a
densifié notre partenariat on a amené du
public au stade donc effectivement sur
le plan sportif c'est un peu décevant
mais je v toute la partie environnement
et le club a franchi un cap et a
énormément grandi cette année